We have a voicemail number two one nine two
David p.
There is a color known to us as the Kansas
troll.
This is a guy who actually called into Sam
Cedar's show with horribly racist stuff.
I think the video on Sam Cedar's channel is
something like, um, incredibly stupid young
man tries to argue with Sam about the bell
curve or something like that.
He's called into us before he's actually called
in live and he face planted with something
about Alex Jones and me selling supplements.
He will often call in and attack me for my
position on a story I, I never covered and
that's exactly what he's doing today.
He's resurfaced and he is attacking me for
my terrible coverage of some Hispanic girl
that was crying.
I don't even know what he's talking about,
but certainly not a story that I cover.
Take a listen to this.
Do you ever shut up Ackman anyways?
Uh, you know, you're talking about this little,
uh, he just literally illegal immigrant girl
crying, you know, boo hoo, you know [inaudible]
Nick, David, nobody cares.
Like you know, they can just take packings
like you did.
You can go straight back to Argentina.
I mean you can go back to Europe.
We never regionally, where are you?
Even from David [inaudible] who none of us
even know where you're from.
You know.
So anyways, you know, this little Mexican
and legal as she can.
No, you didn't go to work.
She can go look for some turbinado you know,
he'll some, yeah.
Worthless [inaudible] or CC looking for work.
Yes.
I can help her even if you want, you know,
getting contact with the little illegal girl
and I'll get her a job.
Right.
Thanks Jeff.
Yup.
Never covered the story.
Don't know what you're talking about.
And it's weird.
A lot of the trolls regularly call in to criticize
me for my view on stories I've just not talked
about.
There's this other guy, the San Antonio troll.
People wonder why when I see two one zero
pop up during live calls, I say San Antonio's
a problematic area code for us.
It's because of the San Antonio troll who
also calls in with just devastating takedowns
of me for stories I've not even covered.
Really Weird.
Try calling and talking to me about something
I've actually discussed.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Walmart banning violent
imagery, but not something else that they
should probably ban if they want to deal with
violence.
We'll also talk about the most overworked
cities in the United States.
The list might surprise you, and lastly,
the space force is closer to launching and
we will talk about that all on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access by becoming a member or
a patron.
I'll talk to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.